[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis schönen guten Abend ein Blick
aufs DFB-Pokalfinale und mehr im Sport
von Norbert Lehmann einen schönen guten
Tag von mir schauen wir auf unseren
Nachrichtenthemen
neue Spurensuche nach dem Anschlag auf
die ostseepipelines ermitteln die fahren
da jetzt auch in Brandenburg
was bringt die künstliche Intelligenz
viele hoffen auf Erleichterungen im
Alltag andere warnen vor einer
unbeherrschbaren Gefahrenquelle
und 20 Jahre europäische maßmission sie
liefert viele Erkenntnisse über unseren
Nachbarn auch überraschender
[Musik]
wer ist für die Explosionen an den
Gaspipelines von Nord Stream
verantwortlich eine Spur für den Ukraine
und diese Spur könnte sich jetzt
verdichten wie die Bundesanwaltschaft
heute mitteilte wurde in Brandenburg
eine Wohnung durchsucht die Durchsuchung
steht im Zusammenhang mit einem
möglicherweise ukrainischen
Tatverdächtigen Einzelheiten von
Christoph
die Andromeda 15 Meter lang eine
gemütliche Yacht versegeltörns dringend
im Verdacht Tatfahrzeug zu sein
Ermittler fanden auf ihr Spuren von
Sprengstoff außerdem Spuren von DNA
indirekt führten die jetzt auch nach
Brandenburg
im Rahmen der Ermittlungen hat die
Bundesanwaltschaft am 25 Mai 2023 die
Wohnung einer nicht Verdächtigen Person
in Frankfurt oder durchsuchen lassen
diese Zeugin soll mit einem der
möglichen Attentäter ein Kind haben der
Mann mit mindestens sieben verschiedene
Identitäten soll auch Angehöriger des
ukrainischen Militärs sein heißt es aus
Sicherheitskreisen bei dem Kind wurden
DNA Proben genommen sollten die zu der
DNA auf der Andromeda passen würde dies
belegen dass der Vater an Bord der
Segelyacht war
die Sprengung von nordstream ein
Verbrechen von Ukrainern Beweise gibt es
nicht aber weitere Indizien die
Andromeda war zwar vom polnischen
Warschau aus angemietet worden von einer
Briefkastenfirma in diesem Gebäude aber
die Spur der entsprechenden E-Mail führt
nach Informationen des Spiegels per
Meter Daten in die Ukraine die
Bundesregierung kommentiert all das sehr
zurückhaltend ich würde aber da auch
noch mal um Geduld bitten bis
tatsächlich die Ermittlung beendet sind
weil das im Moment sicher doch noch im
Bereich der Spekulationen bewegt
Erklärungsversuche zum Sabotage
kriminalzstream gibt es viele Russland
USA Norwegen alle standen schon im
Verdacht und natürlich könnte es auch
eine falsche Fährte sein die jetzt
Richtung Ukraine führt aber über die
Ermittlungen reden überfällig sei das
sagt ein mit der Sache vertrauter
Parlamentarier ich glaube dass es nach
Monaten notwendig ist dass die
Öffentlichkeit informiert wird über den
Stand der Dinge denn sonst gedeihen
die Verschwörungstheorien dabei ist
gerade die ukrainische Spur diplomatisch
heikel vor allem zwei Fragen drängen
sich auf was wusste möglicherweise Kiew
und könnte all das ein Schatten auf das
ukrainische Bündnis mit dem Westen
werfen
wieder und wieder ist Kiew das Ziel
russischer Raketen mehr als ein Dutzend
Marschflugkörper und Kampfdrohnen sollen
in der Nacht auf die ukrainische
Hauptstadt abgefeuert worden sein das
Flugabwehrsystem habe alles abgefangen
teilte das Militär mit die Trümmerteile
trafen aber trotzdem Wohngebiete und
beschädigten Häuser
Russland spricht unterdessen von neuen
ukrainischen Angriffen in der
Grenzregion Belgrad dutzende Menschen
sollen laut Staatsfernsehen inzwischen
geflohen sein
in Südafrika haben sich die
Außenministerin und Minister der
brix-staaten also Brasilien Russland
Indien China und Südafrika getroffen bei
den Beratungen geht es unter anderem um
eine Erweiterung der Staatengruppe der
russische Außenminister love sagte der
Westen müsse mit seinem vormacht Streben
zurückstecken zu ihrem Gipfeltreffen im
August in Johannesburg hat die
brix-gruppe auch den russischen
Präsidenten Putin eingeladen trotz eines
internationalen Haftbefehls
ehemalige Kampfpiloten der Bundeswehr
sind als Ausbilder für Chinas Luftwaffe
tätig das zeigen Recherchen von Spiegel
und ZDF frontal das ist besonders
brisant da China von der Bundesregierung
als systemischer Rivale gesehen wird und
es die Sorge gibt dass die Deutschen
Kampfpiloten geheime Einsatz Taktiken
der Bundeswehr und der NATO weitergeben
könnten Christian Rode und ulrich-
mehrere ehemalige deutsche Kampfpiloten
bilden seit Jahren Piloten des
chinesischen Militärs aus das haben
gemeinsame Recherchen von ZDF frontal
und Spiegel ergeben Geheimdienst
Kontrolleure des Deutschen Bundestags
sind alarmiert wir haben die Sorge das
Soldaten und Soldaten
nach ihrer Beschäftigung für den
deutschen Staat
in Beschäftigungsverhältnis geraten
können in denen sie Staatsgeheimnisse
verraten und das ein erhebliches
Sicherheitsrisiko für Deutschland Europa
und die NATO darstellen könnte wer sind
diese deutschen Piloten die nun in China
zum Sicherheitsrisiko werden ein
Dokument aus dem Jahr 2016 listet einige
von ihnen auf Alexander h Eurofighter
Ausbilder Dirk JX Tornado Pilot und
Peters
sie alle sind demnach luftfahrtberater
im Auftrag der Firma low technology mit
Sitz in Peking der Mann hinter Lot ist
zu bin ein Spionen Diensten Pekings 2016
in den USA verurteilt dann ausgeliefert
nach China zu bin hatte geheime Daten zu
NATO Flugzeugen gestohlen
China rüstet auf auch mit Hilfe
deutscher Piloten
Bundesverteidigungsminister Pistorius
ist derzeit in Singapur zur asiatischen
Sicherheitskonferenz erkundigt
Konsequenzen an
jeder Einzelfall muss geprüft werden das
müssen wir konnten werden wir konsequent
machen und alle Überschreitungen werden
geahndet das ist völlig eindeutig sein
Ministerium kündigte an man wolle
gemeinsam mit den deutschen
Nachrichtendiensten Zitat aktiv die
weitere Anwerbung von Piloten verhindern
der ehemalige Bundeswehr Pilot Peters
erklärte er habe keine Militär Geheimnis
verraten alle anderen haben auch
Nachfragen nicht reagiert
und mehr zur Recherche des Teams von
Frontal können Sie auch in unserer ZDF
heute App finden alle Einzelheiten
ausführlich zum durchklicken und
nachlesen
leipzig bereitet sich auf ein Wochenende
der extreme vor denn die linksautonome
Szene hat Bundes und europaweit
mobilisiert und zum Protest aufgerufen
zum Tag X trotz Verbots der Anlass die
mehrjährige Haftstrafe für die Studentin
Lina eh aus Leipzig wegen Überfällen auf
rechtsextreme noch ist es ruhig aber
erste Anhänger und Anhängerin der Szene
haben sich versammelt und vor Ort in
Leipzig ist für uns Cornelia schimansk
Cornelia womit rechnet die Stadt
ja die Stadt rechnet mit größeren
Ausschreitungen und hat in zwölf
Bundesländern Polizisten angefordert
weil niemand so richtig weiß was heute
Abend noch und vor allen Dingen morgen
im Laufe des Tages hier passieren wird
seit 18 Uhr gilt den großen Teilen der
Stadt ein sogenannter Kontrollbereich
das heißt jeder kann anlasslos
kontrolliert werden weil angekündigt
haben sich ja mehrere gewaltbereite
linke Gruppen aus ganz Deutschland und
die sollen möglichst gar nicht erst in
die Stadt gelangen die Demo Tag X die
ist verboten und deshalb rechnet man
damit dass sich die Gewalt womöglich an
dezentralen Orten in der ganzen Stadt
entladen könnte wir haben an diesem
Wochenende die besondere Lage das
Unmengen an Menschen in der Stadt sein
werden weil es ist Stadtfest es gibt das
Sachsenderby Chemnitz gegen Lok Leipzig
und dann auch noch ein Konzert von
Herbert Grönemeyer und deshalb haben
Polizeipräsident und und Innenminister
Schuster sich heute noch mal versichert
das Gebot der Stunde müssen die
Eskalation sein sie werden aus Leipzig
danke schön
in kürzester Zeit ganze Aufsätze
schreiben lassen oder durch einfache
Eingaben Bilder erstellen das alles kann
inzwischen durch künstliche Intelligenz
schnell gelöst werden der Staat der
Anwendung Chat GPT hat im Netz ein
weltweiten Hype ausgelöst und das war
erster Anfang große Tech-Unternehmen wie
Google Facebook Microsoft oder Apple
treiben die KI-Forschung voran viele
sind fasziniert von den Möglichkeiten
der künstlichen Intelligenz hunderte
Fachleute warten allerdings zuletzt auch
vor extremen riesigen vergleichbar mit
Pandemie oder Atomkrieg Sven Regen
berichtet
mit journey heißt eines der beliebtesten
Online-Programme das Bilder erzeugt eine
einfache Beschreibung genügt und die
künstliche Intelligenz im Hintergrund
bastelt scheinbar aus dem Nichts vier
Vorschläge die sind so gut wie die
Trainingsdaten mit denen die Software
etwa gelernt hat wie ein menschliches
Gesicht aussieht wenn ich ganz häufig
dieses Gesicht trainiert habe oder viele
Gesichter trainiert habe dann weiß eine
KI oha das ist eine Nase das ist ein
Auge das ist ein Ohr und kann eben
entsprechend ähnliche Bilder wieder
erzeugen so stellt sich mit Jenny etwa
den Untergang der Menschheit vor
verursacht durch künstliche Intelligenz
die namhaften Unterzeichner dieser
Erklärung setzen dann auch die
Gefährlichkeit von KI gleich mit
Pandemien oder einem Atomkrieg da muss
man sich schon fragen welche
strategischen Überlegungen sind dahinter
wenn man jetzt plötzlich für alle
anderen in welches Tops oder Regulierung
fordert aber alles was man bisher selber
gemacht hat sei natürlich völlig
unproblematisch künstliche Intelligenz
ist ohnehin der falsche Begriff Masch
schnelles Lernen nenne das Informatiker
wenn Computer in kürzester Zeit riesige
Datenmengen durchsuchen am Ende gibt das
System die wahrscheinlichste Antwort die
aber muss nicht richtig sein auch
deshalb sind die meisten Anwendungen
Assistenten die endgültige Entscheidung
trifft ein Mensch das schöne ist es gibt
so viele Start-ups die sich befreit
haben von der großen Diskussion die
einfach gucken oh schau mal mit diesem
Algorithmus kann ich dieses Problem
lösen oder ich kann diese Arbeit diesen
Task besser machen klar eine
Parkraumüberwachung mit KI könnte auch
für eine Gesichtserkennung missbraucht
werden ein ähnlicher Algorithmus aber
schlägt in dieser Bäckerei Kette vor wie
viele Brötchen in den Ofen kommen eine
kundenprognose auf Basis von 11 Jahren
Datensammlung es kommt eben auf den
Einsatzzweck an und den geben Menschen
vor
wie also reguliert man die künstliche
Intelligenz die Vorsitzende des
deutschen integrades Alena Büchs fordert
Texte und Bilder die mit KI generiert
wurden und häufig täuschend echt
aussehen sollten klagekennzeichnet
werden müssen und auch die Politik sucht
Wege die KI zu regulieren Christian
hübscher
fragt man die künstliche Intelligenz
selbst was ihr Albtraum Szenario für die
Zukunft ist dann überlegt der Roboter
auf einer Londoner Messe nur kurz und
sagt dann Vermögen das schlimmstmögliche
albtraumszenario dass ich mir vorstellen
kann ist eine Welt in der Roboter so
mächtig werden dass sie Menschen
kontrollieren und manipulieren ohne dass
Sie es merken die Maschinen lernen
schnell die Politik versucht Schritt zu
halten der deutsche digitalminister
sucht mit seinen Amtskollegen in
Luxemburg nach Regulierungsmöglichkeiten
maßvoll aber schnell es braucht regeln
wir brauchen die Durchsetzung unserer
demokratischen Werte wir müssen
Transparenz sicherstellen und eben am
Ende auch
garantieren das künstliche Intelligenz
und dient aber nicht manipuliert schon
heute nutzt zum Beispiel die AFD
Maschinen generierte bilder wie dieses
wo sie vor mehr Flüchtlingen warnt ein
schwer erkennbarer Fake man könnte
gesetzlich vorschreiben künstlich
erzeugte Bilder zu kennzeichnen durch
digitale Wasserzeichen zum Beispiel
fordert nicht nur die digital-expertin
der Linken wir brauchen eine breite
Aufklärungskampagne und zwar eher
gestern als morgen denn diese große
Welle an solchen Desinformationen kommt
wir haben auch Wahlen anstehen längst
wird auch ein autonomen Waffen geforscht
weil aber eine ki-verordnung noch zwei
bis drei Jahre brauchen wird setzt die
EU vorerst auf freiwillige
Selbstverpflichtung
wir werden in den nächsten Wochen einen
Verhaltenskodex erarbeiten zu dem sich
die Industrie freiwillig verpflichten
kann
doch ob sich ein solch freiwillige
Leitlinien wirklich alle in der
KI-Forschung halten werden ungewiss
die Türkei hat gewählt Präsident Erdogan
bleibt an der Macht gleichzeitig fanden
Mitte Mai die Parlamentswahlen statt und
auch dabei wurde die erdoganpartei AKP
gemeinsam mit verbündeten stärkste Kraft
viele befürchten dass diese
Wahlergebnisse dem autokratischen Kurs
Erdogans weiteren Antrieb geben erste
Anzeichen dafür gab es schon
eine Wahlurne machen noch keine
Demokratie meinte die TV-Journalistin
gidem Toka am Wahlabend im türkischen
Sender Fox solche und ähnliche Kritik an
Präsident Erdogans autoritärer Regierung
rief den Vorsitzenden der staatlichen
Medien auf sich auf den Plan er
twitterte dass es gegen insgesamt sieben
Sender Untersuchungen wegen Beleidigung
des Staates geben werde Mitglieder der
Opposition im Vorstand der Medien
Aufsicht waren nicht informiert und
zeigten sich entsetzt
Vorsitzende versucht hat zu zeigen wie
eifrig er bei der Arbeit ist er scheint
damit mit dem Palast oder einigen in der
Regierung sagen zu wollen seht her ich
belehre jeden der nicht derselben
Ansicht ist wie ihr und euch kritisiert
der Präsident besuchte heute die
Vereidigung der neuen Abgeordneten im
Parlament dort stellt sein Parteien
Bündnis wieder einmal die Mehrheit mit
dem neuen Mandat im Rücken werde der
Druck auf Opposition und kritische
Presse weiter zunehmen ist sich Erol
Änderungen von Reporter ohne Grenzen
sicher
wir glauben dass die türkische
Medienaufsicht ein Instrument im
Unterdrückungsapparat der Regierung ist
ihr Ziel ist es kritische Fernsehsender
durch Strafen einzuschüchtern
und damit die Opposition weiter zu
schwächen die verweigerte heute im
Parlament den Präsidenten den Applaus
verhärtete Fronten in einem gespaltenen
Land
jetzt ist es offiziell die US-Regierung
wird auch am Montag noch ihre Rechnungen
zahlen können nach dem
Repräsentantenhaus hat jetzt auch der
Senat dem Haushaltskompromiss zwischen
Demokraten und Republikanern zugestimmt
die staatliche Schulden Obergrenze wird
nun bis nach der nächsten
Präsidentenwahl ausgesetzt ein
Zahlungsausfall der USA hätte weltweit
die Finanzmärkte und die Wirtschaft
belastet
die ESA feiert Jubiläum die europäische
Weltraumorganisation startete vor genau
20 Jahren maßexpress die erste
europäische Mission zu unserem
Nachbarplaneten damals mit an Bord der
Raumsonde der Lande Roboter Biegel 2 der
aber ging bei seinem Landeanflug
verloren
doch abgesehen davon verläuft die
Mission bis heute erfolgreich
marsexpress liefert unter anderem Daten
zur Atmosphäre des roten Planeten
erforscht seine Oberfläche und blickt
auch darunter wohin Weise auf Wasser
entdeckt wurden aus dem Kontrollzentrum
in Darmstadt berichtet Markus weuselfer
im Hauptkontrollraum der ESA sind die
Erinnerungen ganz nah 2 juni 2003 der
Start von marsexpress um 19:45 Uhr und
26 Sekunden ist es soweit eine russische
Sojus Rakete schießt die Sonde in die
Umlaufbahn ein Bilderbuchstart
groß der Jubel bei den Wissenschaftlern
für sie hat die Mission auch nach 20
Jahren nichts von ihrem Zauber verloren
für mich gibt es keinen besseren Job als
eine Raumsonde um den Mars zu lenken es
ist ein extrem aufregender Job
in all den Jahren gab es mehrere große
Herausforderungen es war immer wieder so
knapp und wir hätten die Sonde fast
verloren
haben sie aber nicht statt ursprünglich
zwei Jahre ist marsexpress nun schon 20
Jahre unterwegs sammelt verlässlich
Daten in Darmstadt feiern sie heute das
Jubiläum die Sonne hat mittlerweile fast
die gesamte Oberfläche analysiert
faszinierende Bilder vom Roten Planeten
spektakulär der Nachweis von Wasser
Eiskappen an den Polen und riesige
ausgetrocknete Flussbetten unter der
Oberfläche vermuten die Forscher zu dem
große Mengen Wasser ja man kann die
Mission wirklich als Bahn brechen
bezeichnen weil sie nicht nur Europas
älteste
langzeitplanetenmission ist sondern auch
sieben verschiedene Instrumente an Bord
hat die den Mars in all seinen Facetten
untersuchen können das gesamte Bild ist
Mars mit einem Satelliten
und dieser Planet ist mehr als nur rot
die Wissenschaftler haben heute ein
Mosaik veröffentlicht es zeigt den Maßen
bisher ungekannter Farbenpracht
marsexpress sei Dank
sieht schon schick aus jetzt kommen wir
zu den Norbert und zum
DFB-Pokalfinale morgen in Berlin Leipzig
gegen Frankfurt und RB ist ja zurzeit
echt in Topform der Titelverteidiger
zuletzt mit fünf bundesligasiegenden
Folge die Eintracht immer besonders
stark in k.o Spielen etwa beim Europa
liegt Triumph 2022 also ein Finale
durchaus auf Augenhöhe
Leipzig mit Bundesliga Torschützenkönig
Christopher dem französischen Superstar
und Eintracht mit Landsmann kolomyani
einen den ganz Europa haben will
RB ist Titelverteidiger wir haben eine
riesen Chancen Titel zu verteidigen und
ähm das haben nicht so viele
Mannschaften geschafft Frankfurt 2018
Pokalsieger und mit Trainer Glasner
letztes Jahr Europa liegt Champion
natürlich wäre es auch eine grandiose
Geschichte im zweiten Jahr zum zweiten
Mal mit einem Pokal nach Hause zu kommen
für Glasner der Frankfurt verlässt was
heute die letzte Trainingseinheit im
Berliner Olympiastadion
das Spiel morgen Abend live bei uns zu
sehen ab 19:25 Uhr und zuvor ein anderes
Fußball-Highlight im ZDF ab 15:45 Uhr
das Champions League Finale der Frauen
in einhofen Barcelona gegen Wolfsburg
die dfb-pokalsiegerinnen den zweiten
Saison an
die Champions League gewann Wolfsburg
zuletzt vor neun Jahren gegen die beste
Vereinsmannschaft der Welt sind sie
Außenseiterinnen aber keineswegs
chancenlos das haben in dieser Saison
auch schon andere Mannschaften bewiesen
wie es geht gegen Barcelona es ist auch
dass Duell zweier topstürmerinnen Alex
Popp gegen Alexia puteas die
Weltfußballerin vom FC Barcelona zeigt
großen Respekt wir wissen dass wir gegen
eines der besten europäischen
Teamspielen jede falsche Entscheidung
wird uns in Schwierigkeiten bringen
im Halbfinale gegen Arsenal erzählte
Wolfsburg kurz vor Schluss das Siegtor
so schön jubeln würden sie morgen gerne
auch noch mal
Fußball-Bundesligisten Mönchengladbach
hat sich nach nur einem Jahr von seinem
Trainer Daniel Farke getrennt damit geht
die Borussia zum dritten Mal
nacheinander mit einem neuen Coach in
die neue Saison der Nachfolger steht
noch nicht fest zur Relegation in der
Fußball-Bundesliga da hat erst linkes
Stuttgart den HSV im Hinspiel klar mit
drei zu null geschlagen die VfB-Führung
bereits nach 44 Sekunden durch Europa
muss der Zweitligist aus Hamburg danach
weitgehend chancenlos gegen starke
Stuttgarter die nehmen den 13:0 durch
die in der 54 Minute noch weitere Tore
hätten erzählen können das Rückspiel
Montag in Hamburg
ja da muss schon echt das mittelschweres
Fußballwunder passieren damit die
Hamburger doch noch den Aufstieg
schaffen
ein sommerliches Wochenende
märz oder Abend das heute journal können
Sie an diesem Abend um 22 Uhr sehen mit
Dunja Hayali auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
ja guten Abend der satellitenfilm von
heute zeigt uns hier dieses Wolkenband
das den Himmel heute morgen teils
bedeckte das wurde jetzt im Tagesverlauf
immer schmaler und diese lockeren Wolken
hier kommen jetzt heute Nacht etwas
südwärts voran lösen sich aber mehr und
mehr auf sonst neben ein paar harmlosen
Wolken ist der Himmel die meiste Zeit
klar und das heißt es geht hinab mit den
Temperaturen im Westen und im Süden
bleibt es in den Städten zwar
zweistellig im Nordosten kann es bis
morgen früh aber bis zu drei Grad kalt
werden inklusive Bodenfrost tagsüber ist
das im Moment aber anders unter
Hochdruck Einfluss kann sich die
trockene Luft schnell erwärmen und zwar
auf 17 Grad an der Nordsee und 27 Grad
am Rhein große Temperaturunterschiede im
Moment also zwischen den früh und den
Nachmittagsstunden und auch zwischen
Nord und Süd der Tag startet mit viel
Sonne die harmlosen Wolken im Norden und
Südosten stören kaum es gibt ein
lebhaften Ostwind nachmittags werden die
Quellwolken im Süden aber dichter und
Mauer und Gewitter über dem
Südschwarzwald und den Alpen sind
wahrscheinlicher als noch heute und
dieser Schauer und Gewitter können am
Montag und am Dienstag auch in
Deutschland mal etwas nördlicher
ausgreifen die Wolken an der Nordsee
sind teilweise recht hartnäckig hier
dann nur um 17 Grad für die allermeisten
gibt es in den nächsten Tagen aber
sommerlichen Sonnenschein und Wärme bis
28 Grad tschüss